docteur eric sauvage our médecin de
famille qui travaille dans un de ces
centres désignés d'évaluation donc ces
nouvelles cliniques divers dr sauvageau
bonsoir merci d'être là et de plaisir
alors pour simplifier pour vous montrer
le tableau avec tous les symptômes des
pandas symptômes qui s'apparentent un
symptôme de la coved mais aussi du rhume
et de la grippe dont fièvre perte de
goût fatigue perte d'appétit douleurs
tout congestion en difficulté à respirer
et cetera et cetera et cetera
on sera dans une clinique désigné on
sera pas n'importe où c'est ça
exactement c'est les symptômes qu'on dit
chaud et donc on veut pas se présenter
dans une clinique irrégulière compte 10
froide parce qu'on veut protéger nos
milieux froid et donc si vous ressentez
le besoin de consulter vous avez un de
ces symptômes bleus il faut soit se
faire dépister et où rencontrer un
médecin dans un de ces centres désignés
le effectivement comment je sais moi si
ma clinique traditionnel un froide ou
chaude avec général et son toute froide
si vous voulez être sûr que vous allez
porter dans un lieu froid mais vous
appeler au numéro que vous avez donnée
au jeu 6-4 4-4 5 4 5 ou sur internet
vous remplissez votre questionnaire que
senna de tours évaluation où vous vous
trouvez votre centre de dépistage que 28
9 dans votre quartier si mon enfant une
otite
oui je fais quoi je vais ou si c'est
seulement seulement mal d'oreille isolé
ou un seul un mal de gorge aux olives
vous pourriez présenter un qui ne croît
de 6 donc oui je comprends que c'est
mais l'aja je suis là ça va bien je sais
il dit
si on a sur la portion de la fièvre si
le nez jeudi l'enfant ça peut être le
mien le nez cole fièvre et qui s'appelle
sable à covilha évidemment ça va pas
dans une clinique qui est pas désigné
l'on va on appelle ou 6 4
404 5 on devrait garder sa part fait
donc on appelle là bas ils vont vous
dire allez à tel endroit à tel endroit
pour faire tester exactement dans le
cadre des enfants même on demande une
période d'observation de 24 heures avant
d'appeler mais après ça vous appeler
pour vous dire jouer au bon endroit
c'est pas plus compliqué que ce qu'on a
appelé les cliniques du verre qui ont
jamais vraiment existé le système vue de
l'esprit c'est des cliniques
traditionnels dont on allongeait les
heures d'ouverture donc ça n'existe plus
il y aura pas d heures allongé ou bien
est-ce qu'il y aura des heures allongé
mais on va on va se concentrer sur la
commune mais je peux parler pour les
orientations ministérielles le met
effectivement en ce moment il ya peu
clinique vers tous les symptômes
infectieux sont dirigés vers les centres
de dépistage ou les fameuses c d e
par contre ce qui est demandé aux
praticiens médecins de famille comme moi
en période de pandémie c'est d'offrir un
service populationnelle plus qu'à
l'habitude le pour aider la population à
se trouver ce qui est un médecin qui
répondent à leurs besoins de santé ips
pour ce faire peu importe besoin de 100
pays
les jeunes devraient plus au 8-1-1 tout
simplement pour dire j'ai pas de médecin
ou j'ai un médecin mais je pense capable
de rejoindre
j'ai besoin de parler à un médecin puis
l'origine erreur va trouver un médecin
répondra par téléphone juste que je
comprenne quand vous quand vous dites
ils nous ont demandé d'être plus
disponible pour les besoins de la
population dont vous allez faire plus
d'heures que mon travail je vous dirais
que c'est pas juste les médecins les
infirmières tout le personnel de la
santé oms est fatigué mais c'est un coup
à donner dans nos poches aux attaquants
emile est donc quand on dit dans
d'autres dossiers avant même la
pandémique
dans certains cas il ya des médecins de
famille qui travaille pas assez d'heures
qu'ils n'ont pas cette patience en ce
moment selon votre expérience autour de
vous les médecins rôle à 100% pas mal
je dirais qu'ils relâchent 150 pour ça
dc c'est tout le réseau les intentions
si le beurre de pinottes saada c'est pas
mal est allé un peu partout parce qu'il
ya des torts d'urgence sont des doubles
il ya des nouveaux des nouvelles
cliniques cdm transmises sur piste sous
scellés les mêmes personnes qui font
qu'ils doivent qui doivent offrir des
services supplémentaires qui ont dû être
créés à cause de pandémie
donc on donc c'est sûr qu'on essaie de
partout à la fois le skipper et a donc
quand vous entendez le premier me laisse
le goût demandé des efforts encore aux
québécois pour un un autre moi et c'est
à vous vous comprenez exactement
pourquoi on demande ça c'est que leur
région on tire dessus puis on y est
vraiment au bout l'élastique est au bout
de ce que je vois des statistiques
est ce que je comprenne ya encore de la
place mais évidemment on veut pas que
l'élastique pefc c'est vraiment pour ce
qu'on demande ces efforts là donc
voulez-vous vous adhérer totalement aux
efforts collectifs qu'on demande aux
gens là oui absolument pas si je peux
passer un message à population si vous
avez un test de dépistage
restez chez vous s'il vous plaît en
attendant le résultat le spo litana
lobbing goal com ag j'ai vu dernièrement
sous fait des bêtises parce que vous
restez chez vous en attendant le
résultat puisque si la santé publique
adedy appellent ça fait un appel masqué
s'il vous plaît répondez aux appels
masqués s'appelle la santé publique ça
peut être votre médecin qui est cette
bourgeoise donc c'est important de
répondre aux appels masqués d'auteur etc
sera jour je serai content d'en reparler
veut voir son de cloche à quelqu'un qui
est dans une clinique que vous êtes à
sorel-tracy
je le rappelle bombay le numéro est la 1
8 7 7 6 4 4 45 45 c'est le fameux numéro
morial aussi en a un autre qui
fonctionne sur les 6 4 4 avec le 5 1 4
autrement ça fonctionne peu importe le
code régional j'aurais compris que c'est
le même numéro
merci docteur bonne chance pour
la suite merci au revoir